I will always remember
my son's first day of school.
Lucas was five years old
and he was going to kindergarten,
and he was so excited.
He was going to take the bus.
and we were excited for him.
And I’ll never forget
that day when I came home,
I was eager to check in with him
to hear, "How did it go?"
And Lucas's response was,
"Dad, I'm tired of hearing
about hallway procedures."
(Laughter)
I found his response both amusing and sad.
Amusing because I thought, oh my gosh,
you have a lifetime of hallway procedures
you're going to have to work through.
And also amusing
because it captured so well
how schools and institutions
can just grind us down
with their bureaucratic rules
and monotonous procedures.
But I found it sad because this
was his first day of school,
and his takeaway on that very first day,
was that school is boring.
This is a boring place.
However, he's going to have to learn
to deal with boredom.
It's something we all learn to deal with.
Boredom is a common and familiar problem.
And I think at first it can seem
like a trivial problem.
If you're bored,
just find something interesting,
move on to the next thing.
But actually, I’m going to argue
that it’s far more complex.
And that it needs our attention.
And I'm going to offer three takeaways
for how to contend with boredom well.
In schools, boredom is a big problem.
An overwhelming majority
of high school students
report being bored in school.
And this is a problem because when
students are bored in school,
they begin to lose interest,
they can't focus.
And when students are bored in school,
they start to misbehave.
I was a high school teacher,
and if my students were bored,
I was petrified because I was
going to have problems.
This was going to be a disaster.
And if students are chronically
bored year after year,
eventually they just drop out
and peel away from school altogether.
But boredom is not just
a problem in schools.
It's a problem that tracks us
beyond schools.
There are several troubling addictions
that are linked to boredom.
When we're bored, we drink too much,
we eat too much,
we spend too much money,
we buy things we don't need.
There are entire industries
that are designed around making us bored.
And so boredom has some really problematic
behaviors linked to it,
but even more than these
troubling addictions,
there are also these smaller things.
The half-listening to friends
and acquaintances when we’re bored.
Or just the way we idle our time
when we’re bored.
I'm dating myself,
but if I could take back
the 10,000 hours I put into Tetris
and put that into actually playing guitar,
I'd be a professional musician right now.
That was kind of a joke, anyway.
So, boredom is something
we need to look at,
and we look at boredom,
we tend to think about it objectively.
I’m bored by this teacher
or I’m bored by this book I’m reading
or this person I'm talking to.
And boredom tends to objectify things
and actually be quite
judgmental and arrogant.
That's a boring person,
that's a boring book.
But in truth, boredom is both
objective and subjective.
We're actually making a judgment call,
deciding whether
something is boring or not.
And we know that what bores one person
could actually be very
interesting to another.
So in this respect,
boredom is kind of a curious
and perplexing mood state.
What do we make of it?
It's kind of like a dashboard light,
when you're in your car
and a light goes on
and it gives you very clear directives.
You need to get gas, you need to get oil,
you need to put air in the tires.
The problem with the boredom light is
it goes on and there's no clear direction.
We're not sure what to do with it,
and most of the time we don't even notice
the boredom dashboard light
because it's going on all the time.
It's kind of blinking
and it just becomes white noise
and we're dealing with it.
We're dealing without even realizing it.
Day in and day out,
we're constantly navigating away
from boring spaces
into interesting spaces.
And how do we do this?
There are two dominant ways
that we've evolved to contend
with this troubling mood state.
On the one hand, you've got avoidance.
So if I'm in a boring situation,
the first move we make is,
how do I get out of this?
I can physically get out of this,
or what do I do?
I daydream.
Or the most obvious thing we do
is we check our phones.
Our phones are these sophisticated
boredom-avoidance devices.
And we avoid boredom
because it’s actually painful.
I don't know if you've ever felt
the pain of boredom.
The pain of boredom
was illustrated in a recent study
at the University of Virginia.
They asked subjects to come into a room
and just sit with their
thoughts for 15 minutes.
And these are folks that were 18 to 70.
And they could do that,
or they could put
their finger in a machine
and receive a painful shock.
The results of the study were,
pun intended, shocking:
30 percent of the women
and 60 percent of the men
chose to shock themselves
rather than sit with their thoughts
for 15 minutes.
All of this is to say that we
would rather have physical pain,
many of us, than the pain of boredom.
So avoidance is the common go-to way
that we contend with it
without even thinking about it,
it's automatic.
The other strategy
that we employ is resignation.
You've perhaps heard
grown-ups say to children
when they complain of boredom,
"That's life. Get used to it."
And so the idea is that you
just have to endure it.
You just have to push through it.
I'm a teacher of teachers
and a privilege I get
is I get to see teachers
across all grade levels.
And I've seen some incredible spaces
where the teaching is dynamic, engaging,
it's meaningful.
If there is boredom, it passes.
The students know
how to deal with it in a good way.
But sometimes I go to classes
and it's boring.
And usually in those classes
the students are misbehaving,
and that's completely understandable.
And I would say
even appropriate, sometimes,
to let the teacher know
that they need to change it up here.
But sometimes I go
into a boring classroom
and the students are not misbehaving.
I was in a classroom a few years ago,
a seventh-grade classroom,
and the students were tasked
with copying a PowerPoint,
word for word, for 45 minutes.
I was bored out of my mind.
And I turned to the student
next to me and I said,
"Is this kind of what you do?"
And he said, "We do this every day."
And what amazed me
was the students were docile.
They were compliant.
I expected, I actually hoped
there would be a protest or a revolution.
I thought this teacher should be punished
for having such a boring class.
But instead, the students
just were passive.
They were just resigned.
When my kids were younger,
they would complain to me,
"Dad, I'm so bored,
there's nothing to do."
And there are two things
going on there in that comment.
The first is a lack of imagination.
"I'm so bored, I can't see anything
worthwhile to do."
That's resignation.
And then there's also a loss of agency.
"I'm so bored, there's nothing
I can do to get out of this."
So we have resignation on the one hand
and we have avoidance.
These are the two common strategies
that we employ
without even recognizing it.
I'm interested in what
is a practically wise way,
a middle way between avoidance
on the one hand
and resignation on the other.
And I think about this in light
of two stories from my own life.
After college, I lived in a house
in Chicago with with three teachers.
And one of my roommates, Mark,
I met him the first day
and probably within the first day,
I decided he was just kind of dull.
He kind of took his time
to make his points,
and I decided that I was going to limit
the amount of time I spent with Mark.
I was going to avoid him.
We were roommates, though.
I would see Mark every day.
We used the same bathroom.
Every day after school,
we would talk about teaching.
And I discovered that Mark actually
was a really thoughtful teacher.
He was a creative teacher,
he was an innovative teacher.
And he wasn’t just trying
to improve his teaching,
he was also trying to improve himself.
And he was always thinking
about work and life
and figuring out the right balance.
And over time, I realized
Mark is not boring.
Actually he's wise.
And he's a dear friend to this day.
But my initial assessment of Mark
as a boring person
was just completely wrong.
The mood state was giving me information
that I was not reading correctly.
The second story is from my first year
of high school teaching,
which, the first year is demanding work,
and you're kind of looking
for shelter and comfort.
And I found a group of teachers
to have lunch with
and would go there to eat lunch.
But eventually the conversations
were just complaint sessions,
day in and day out.
And we usually complained
about administrators.
That was our number one target,
especially administrators
who hadn't taught.
Our second complaint was maybe
a difficult student or parent,
but day in and day out,
it was this negative loop.
It was like being stuck in the first
part of the movie "Groundhog Day,"
and it was just unending.
And eventually I just got bored
with this conversation.
And I pulled away.
I began to eat lunch
in my classroom by myself.
But eventually I found other teachers
who were also vigilant about steering
away from complaint culture,
which is addictive.
It seems interesting, but eventually,
it gets very, very boring,
complaint culture.
And instead of complaining,
they would talk about books
they were enjoying
or hobbies that they loved
or what went well in their teaching.
And these were conversations
that I found very interesting.
And also they were restorative.
They lifted my spirits to go in
and teach my classes.
I share these two stories
because in both instances
I was experiencing boredom.
But what to make of it was not clear.
And so I want to offer three takeaways.
And I'm thinking of young people
as they figure out strategies
for contending with this
troubling mood state.
The first takeaway is that boredom
should not be trusted.
We tend to trust boredom.
We make an implicit judgment
about something or someone
and decide it's boring.
And it’s arrogant, it’s judgmental
and often is wrong.
We need to take a careful look
and make sure that there might be
something here worthwhile,
worth attending to.
So don't trust boredom is takeaway one.
The second takeaway is
we need to protect our attention.
A bored mind is primed to get distracted
from distraction by distraction.
It is looking to be distracted.
And when we think about the things
we care about, our friends
or something we’re trying to get good at
or a hobby that we love,
each of these things
will be afflicted by boredom.
It will come.
And if we are in an environment
where we're easily distracted,
boredom will get the better of us.
Don't trust boredom,
protect our attention.
And then finally, we need
to talk about boredom.
We all have strategies that we employ.
We need to name those strategies.
There was a great writer in the '80s
who described our modern life
as a sophisticated
boredom-avoidance scheme.
Walker Percy said that.
The scheme is far more
sophisticated today.
We know that.
But to the extent that we're not
reflecting on it and thinking about it,
boredom plays us
and gets the better of us.
But the extent that we're reflecting
on it and thinking about it,
we can put boredom in its place
and give our attention
and protect our attention
to those things we love
and the people we care about.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)